[Music]  sometimes i wonder what this city looked  like before all this  probably like many others  people had their ambitions plans lives  now it's all gone  the virus started it but it was the  people who made the world the way it is  this city  villador  they tell me they had a vision  they had hope  but soon one vision broke into many  different ones  instead of fighting together  people stood against each other  war broke out  was it a little bird  lit a broken leg hope died  now the city is falling  each time we strike down an enemy we  absorb their strength  but i can't let that happen  at least  not yet  [Applause]  i need the secrets this city holds oh  [ __ ] hey  still some rats here  i have to pick a side the bizarre needs  good people  you're doing great so far  [Music]  i have to make a difference  let's check and see  they say that great change is a series  of small gestures  [Music]  how about this series  is all hope really gone we'll see about  that  now  [Music]